THE DAY BEFORE THE PRESS
CONFERENCE THAT WE DISCUSSED
LAST SEGMENT COW MCNAIR THE
OWNER OF THE TEXANS IN A
LETTER TO SEASON TICKET
HOLDERS SAID THAT THE TEXANS
ARE TAKING THE SITUATION VERY
SERIOUSLY AS REPORTED HPD IN
THE NATIONAL FOOTBALL LEAGUE
OR CONDUCTING INVESTIGATIONS.
WE WILL COOPERATE FULLY
RESPECT THE LEGAL PROCESS. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE
SITUATION CLOSELY THAT WAS
BEFORE YOU TAKE PRESS
CONFERENCE. IT JUST OCCURRED
TO ME. WE HAVEN'T HEARD FROM
THE TEXT AND SINCE
PRESS CONFERENCE. MAYBE THEY
ESPECIALLY SINCE NOW THEY'RE
SORT OF INDIRECTLY BEING
IMPLICATED WE TALKED ABOUT
THAT LAST SEGMENT THE IDEA
THAT THAT BUSBY SAID AT SOME
POINT YOU HAVE AN OBLIGATION
ASK QUESTIONS AND SOMETHING
DOESN'T ADD UP CHRIS IF YOU
HAVE THIS WORLD-CLASS
FACILITY WITH MASSAGE
THERAPIST ON SALARY AND THIS
GUY IS ASKING FOR REFERRALS
FOR MASSAGE THERAPISTS AND
ASKING TO BORROW TABLES FOR
MASSAGES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
OCCURRING OFF-SITE. SOMETHING
DOESN'T ADD UP AND THE
ARGUMENT WILL BE
IF BUSBY PURSUES THIS
DID THE TEXANS KNOW SOMETHING
THEY SHOULD HAVE KNOWN DID
THEY KNOW TO DO SOMETHING.
THEY SHOULD HAVE DONE AND ARE
THE TEXANS RESPONSIBLE HERE,
BUT I LOOKED AT THE TEXANS
CHRIS. THEY ALREADY HAD A
PROBLEM WITH THE SEAN WANTS
AND NOW THEY'VE GOT A PROBLEM
AND I THINK ANY TEAMS EVER
HAD TO DEAL WITH TO THIS
EXTENT. I DON'T THINK SO,
RIGHT AND AND I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY DO. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU CAN DO AT THIS POINT. IF
YOU'RE THE HOUSTON TEXANS, I
DON'T THINK THERE'S MUCH THEY
CAN DO. I MEAN THEY JUST GOT
TO KIND OF SIT BACK AND KIND
OF LET THIS ALL PLAY OUT NOW
I DO I THINK IT'S OUT OF
THEIR HANDS.
YOU KNOW AND AGAIN LISTEN, I
CAN UNDERSTAND THEM ASKING
FOR A PLAYER ASKING A TEAM
FOR REFERRALS OR BORROWING A
MASSAGE TABLE. ALL RIGHT, I
ALL THAT THAT HAPPENS BUT LIKE
TWO OR THREE TIMES OR I'VE
KEPT THAT SAME TABLE FOR A
LONG TIME OR OKAY, TWO OR
THREE TIMES AND NOW I FOUND
THE RIGHT MASSEUSE AND I'M
STICKING WITH THEM BECAUSE
THEY KNOW HOW TO WORK MY BODY
OR DO THOSE THINGS. I MEAN
AGAIN, THAT'S WHAT'S WEIRD.
THESE ARE ATHLETES.
OBSESSED WITH THEIR BODY THEY
KNOW EXACTLY HOW THEY FEEL. I
LIKE THIS MASSEUSE BECAUSE
SHE SHE OR HE UNDERSTANDS MY
JOB WHERE I GET SORE. YOU
KNOW WHERE MY TENDENCIES ARE
TO ALWAYS KIND OF FLARE UP.
WHATEVER THAT MAY BE THAT IN
ITSELF IS FISHY. THERE'S NO
DOUBT ABOUT THAT. I MEAN, I'M
NOT GOING TO SAY THAT IT'S
YOU KNOW AGAIN PYRES DO ASK
FOR REFERRALS AND GET
YEAH, AND YOU WONDER WHY THE
TEXANS WOULDN'T HAVE MAYBE
ASK LIKE WHAT THE HELL'S
GOING ON? WHY HAVEN'T YOU
FOUND ONE YOU REALLY LIKE.
WHAT IS THE ISSUE THERE?
THE NFL ISSUED A STATEMENT
AFTER YESTERDAY'S PRESS
CONFERENCE. HE ALLEGATIONS
ARE DEEPLY DISTURBING AND WE
TAKE THESE ISSUES VERY
SERIOUSLY IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING THE NEWS OF THE
FIRST ALLEGATIONS LAST MONTH
AND HAS BEEN REPORTED. WE
INITIATED AN INVESTIGATION
UNDER THE NFL'S PERSONAL
CONDUCT POLICY. WE ARE
CONTINUING TO CLOSELY MONITOR
ALL DEVELOPMENTS IN THE
MATTER CHRIS. AS I SAID
EARLIER. I THINK THEY HAVE TO
PUT THEM ON THE COMMISSIONER
EXEMPT LIST AT THIS POINT. I
DON'T THINK YOU CAN DO WHAT
THEY'VE DONE IN THE PAST AND
I'VE HAD THESE DISCUSSIONS
WITH PEOPLE FROM THE LEAGUE
OFFICE. WHY ARE YOU NOT DOING
I THINK SOMEONE'S BEEN
ARRESTED. SOMEONE'S BEEN
CHARGED WITH WHATEVER. WELL,
IT'S THE OFFSEASON. THERE'S
REALLY NOTHING TO KEEP THEM
FROM LIKE THERE'S NO NEED TO
MAKE IT. THIS IS MY
INTERPRETATION. YEAH, I DON'T
NEED TO MAKE IT A BIGGER
STORY THAN IT IS BY PUTTING
HIM ON THE COMMISSIONER
EXEMPT LIST BECAUSE THEN WE
BUY ANOTHER NEWS CYCLE WHERE
EVERYONE'S TALKING ABOUT
DESHAUN WATSON. NO REASON TO
DO IT. WHAT DO WE GAIN? HE'S
NOT ON A FOOTBALL FIELD.
ANYWAY, HE'S NOT BEING
TELEVISED BY OUR NETWORK
PARTNERS PEOPLE AREN'T IN THE
AWKWARD POSITION OF HAVING TO
TALK ABOUT HIM. SO THERE'S
AIN'T THERE IS THERE IS TO DO
IS THE RIGHT THING, RIGHT?
YOU GOTTA STAND UP AND YOU
GOTTA SAY THIS DOESN'T FLY.
HE'S ON THE COMMISSIONER
EXEMPT LIST UNTIL FURTHER
NOTICE PERIOD I FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE AT THE POINT WHERE
THEY HAVE TO DO THAT AGREED.
I MEAN, I JUST THINK YEAH,
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE GOING TO
LOSE IN THE COURT OF PUBLIC
OPINION AND SEEM INSENSITIVE
IF THEY DON'T DO THAT HERE
SOON. YOU KNOW AGAIN, HERE'S
THE BIG QUESTION WITH DESHAUN
WATSON. ALL RIGHT, I MEAN
HE'S GONNA GET SUSPENDED I
WOULD BE SHOCKED. I MEAN
I MEAN THAT SEEMS LIKE
INEVITABLE AT THIS.
POINT ALL RIGHT, HOW MANY
GAMES? I DON'T KNOW. HERE'S
MY BIG QUESTION. I MEAN
, IS HE EVER GOING TO PLAY
FOOTBALL AGAIN? I THINK
THAT'S LEGITIMATE LIKE
QUESTION RIGHT NOW AND ARE
LIKE WITH WHAT WE'VE SEEN NOW,
THAT WAS ONE PERSON. WE HAD
YOU KNOW A PUBLIC STATEMENT
FOR FROM YESTERDAY AT LEAST,
YOU KNOW IN PERSON TO SEE THE
FACE AND ALL THAT, YOU KNOW,
IF WE CONTINUE TO GET A FEW
MORE TO GO ALONG WITH IT.
WOW, BUT I JUST
JUST WONDER LIKE OKAY. HOW
DOES THIS LITIGATION PROCESS
TAKE? YOU KNOW, LIKE YOU SAID
IT COULD TAKE A LONG LONG
TIME SO THAT COULD BE ALRIGHT.
WE'VE LOST THE YEAR OF
FOOTBALL JUST BECAUSE HE'S ON
THE COMMISSIONER EXEMPT LIST,
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
YOU KNOW, THE THE THE THE
SYSTEM AND HOW IT GOES THAT
WAY THE CASE ITSELF. SO YOU
HAVE THAT ASPECT BUT THEN
LIKE MIKE I MEAN AS THAT CASE
GOES ON OF COURSE MORE DIRTY
LAUNDRY IS GOING TO BE AIRED
IT'S NOT GOING TO LOOK GOOD
HERE WE ARE IN 2021 OF THE
CURRENT CURRENT CLIMATE AND
THOSE TYPE OF THINGS I AM.
I'M ON THE I'M NOT SURE WE'RE
GOING TO SEE DESHAUN WATSON
PLAY FOOTBALL AGAIN. I THINK
WE'RE GETTING INTO THAT
TERRITORY. YOU'RE ONTO
SOMETHING HERE AND WE'RE
GETTING SHORT ON TIME. BUT I
WANT TO MAKE THIS POINT. YEAH
IF HE CONTINUES TO FIGHT AND
FIGHT AND FIGHT AND FIGHT,
IT'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO GO
POORLY AND POORLY AND POORLY
IN POORLY AT SOME POINT.
YOU'VE GOT TO ACCEPT THIS IF
YOU GOT TO UNDERSTAND WHERE
THIS IS GOING AND IF HE DOES
FIGHT IT ALL THE WAY THROUGH
AND IF A PROSECUTION DOES
ULTIMATELY
LEE START AND IF THERE IS
ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO CONVINCE A
JURY BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT THAT HE VIOLATED THE
LAWS HE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
PLAY FOOTBALL OR DO ANYTHING
ELSE FOR A PERIOD OF YEARS
AND YEARS AND AND AND AND
HERE'S THE COMPARISON. I
WANT TO MAKE MIKE VICK EVEN
THOUGH IS COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT FACTUAL SETTING HE
DENIED HE DENIED HE DENIED
AND THEN HE FINALLY REALIZED
HE WAS BOXED IN AND THERE WAS
ONLY ONE THING TO DO AND HE
PLEADED GUILTY AND HE AND HE
AND HE PAID HIS DEBT TO
SOCIETY AND HE WAS BACK IN
THE NFL ON THE BACK END AT
SOME POINT
YOU'VE GOT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IT'S OVER
AND THAT YOU'VE LOST AND
THAT'S THE HARD CONVERSATION
THAT SOMEONE NEEDS TO HAVE
WITH DESHAUN WATSON BECAUSE
IF YOU FIGHT THIS TOOTH AND
NAIL IS GOING TO COST YOU A
TON OF MONEY. IT'S GOING TO
DERAIL YOUR CAREER AND IT MAY
PUT YOU BEHIND BARS FOR A
VERY LONG TIME IF YOU REFUSE
TO ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT YOU DID,